have you had any other vaccinations in
the last 7 days
daniel peters had no doubt about getting
his booster a commercial airline pilot
without anywhere to fly during the
pandemic daniel became a carer for his
grandparents so i just had my booster
jab my kovid and my flu jab they offered
me it so i decided to get two prongs one
in each arm i live with my grandparents
so i want to make sure i'm protected as
much as possible and also to see family
so my family's back in ireland so
traveling back home to ireland to see
them i want to make sure i'm fully
protected going back
the prime minister seen here at a
vaccination hub in east london has
accepted his scientists recommendation
to make 40 to 49 year olds eligible for
their boosters he says everyone who can
must
sadly there are people in in itu in
intensive care who are who are suffering
badly from from kobe but they're all the
unvaccinated and what's happening is
that if you can get your your booster
then your immunity goes right back up
to encourage take up of the booster the
prime minister said it would be added to
the nhs covet travel pass making it a
necessity for some foreign travel
the urgency to the british government's
booster campaign follows a huge surge in
covet infections in parts of western
europe in austria
a lockdown has been imposed on its
unvaccinated people
not one but two downing street press
conferences today to hammer home its
importance
you said we should take our medicine and
finish the job do you see the finishing
line in sight we're at a very
unpredictable point in the epidemiology
so i i regard it as
still a time of great delicacy and quite
a bit of
near-term danger
but the warning from some scientists is
that the booster campaign on its own
might not be enough to avoid a winter
surge in cases
living with covet doesn't mean letting
preventable deaths occur when they could
be easily prevented by very very minor
restrictions like people wearing masks
and indoor environments and transport in
shops
what is happening in europe right now
could easily be replicated here it's
happened before a mass take up the
booster will go a long way to ensuring
it doesn't
ashish joshi sky news westminster